[Musique]
pour l'instant joe biden est en tête
grâce à sa victoire dans le whisky
signer le michigan pour le candidat
démocrate ce n'est plus qu'une question
d'heures
je ne suis pas ici pour vous dire que
nous avons gagné mais pour vous dire que
lors du décompte final
nous croyons que nous serons les
vainqueurs parce que je ne suis pas
américain jeu je me refuse à ce choix de
je suis français je ne vais pas chercher
mes modèles aux états unis on a en tout
cas l'exemple d'une amérique d'une
démocratie profondément divisée à bout
de passion ces manifestants pro trump du
michigan exige l'arrêt des dépouilles en
arizona
une cinquantaine de militants certains
armés ont réussi à interrompre
momentanément le décompte dans ce bureau
de vote
un seul républicain a regardé les
bulletins de vote ils pourraient
provenir de mars ou du comité national
démocratique
joe biden aurait pu voter 15 fois même
genre quinze mille fois qu'est ce que ça
signifie pour moi c'est qu'il s'agit
d'un effort concerté des escrocs qui
dirige le parti démocrate
et vous savez que les machines de ces
grandes villes sont truquées voici mon
fils joe biden que beaucoup parmi vous
ont aidé à élire au sénat du delaware
voici ma petite fille nathalie
attendez attendez ce n'est pas nathalie
dans un meeting précédent il avait dit
je vous présente ma femme et ma soeur il
s'était trompé passation ya quand même
un problème les années qui viennent de
passer quatre ans en se demandant si
leur président était fou paranoïaque
qu'on parlait de trump l'aï risquent si
mme biden était lui de passer quatre ans
de demander ça leur président est
atteint d'alzheimer
je souhaite vraiment de tout coeur la
victoire de joe biden je trouve que
enfin voila c'est plutôt bien parti
ça va être difficile je vois d'ailleurs
une attitude de très calme très sérieuse
de sa part qui n'est pas tout à fait
celle du président sortant
le musée madame tussaud de berlin a déjà
fait son choix et mais donald trump à la
poubelle postée sur le compte instagram
du musée la mise en scène arbore le
slogan d'hommes trump littéralement
jetée trump à la poubelle nous faisons
de la place pour le prochain président
vous pouvez toujours en contre et rome
dans cette configuration jusqu'à
dimanche inclus
la situation dans notre pays elle est
très sérieuse la deuxième vague n'est
donc pas une abstraction mais elle est
là et elle est violente et après le coup
de gueule poussé par olivier véran mardi
soir les députés ont finalement rétabli
l'échéance initiale j'ai été député
européen pendant dix ans si un
commissaire européen avait dit aux
députés européens sortais de là dans
l'hémicycle je pense que lui ce serait
se serait fait sortir oliveira a des
qualités et il est face à des épreuves
donc je vais pas le commenter c'est pas
l'homme qui est en difficulté
un ministre dire au député sorte et
c'est incroyable c'est la négation du
parlement alors peut-être que je veux le
dire n'est pas forcément porté à
l'opinel excusé je veux bien l'excusé au
titre de la fatigue trop de laxisme
il ya trop de tolérance il ya trop de
mesures dérogatoires qui font que les
finalités du confinement qui vise à
empêcher qu'il y ait trop d'interaction
entre les personnes et bien on voit pas
cette diminution des attractions
arrêtons de parler de ce qui a été
décidé qu'il faut accompagner sur le
confinement même si on veut ont critiqué
les modalités surtout la non application
par les citoyens à vous diriez ça
carrément oui donc il y aura fermeture à
22 ans il y aura fermeture à 22 heures
de la restauration adultes et et des
débits de boissons ont pas tout voilà
mais en tous les cas vous verrez
l'arrêté du du préfet de police qui a
été travaillé hier pour lequel j'ai
donné bien sûr mon avis favorable je
suis favorable à ce que nous répondions
en profondeur schengen